photography is often called the universal hobby
it is a means of creative expression within the
reach of people in all walks of life and it
speaks a language that everyone can understand
the camera lens is a mechanical eye seeing
everything and recording everything it captures
actions that will never again be repeated
used with a microscope it records the strange
activities of tiny organisms with the x-ray it
reveals the structure or function of hidden things
if objects move too fast to be seen clearly
by the unaided eye the camera slows them down
so that the action may be studied in contrast
hours of action may be compressed into seconds
photography in one form or another exerts
a great influence on our daily lives
photographs bring news reports to life
they strengthen the appeal of advertising
they provide entertainment for millions and are
an aid to education photography as a hobby can
lead to photography as a career and often
does but professional work calls for a lot
more than just snapping pictures here and there
for instance consider the portrait photographer
to make a real success in this highly
competitive field the cameraman must be
a practical psychologist who understands the
personality of each individual he photographs
people want to look their best in fact better
than they look so the photographer must know
all the tricks of lighting and the posing to
achieve a flattering likeness of the subject
to get good negatives he must
master the chemistry of photography
he should also know how to retouch
negatives to remove wrinkles and blemishes
if he can't do this work himself part of his
income will go for pay to a hired retoucher
making the prints is the most
important step in portrait work
and good printing can only be learned
through long practice and study
all the previous work and the success of
the whole job depends on the final print
if it pleases the subject and her
friends it may lead to more business
and a portrait man must keep busy if he's to
make money the illustrative photographer's
work calls for a well-equipped studio
and a great amount of skill and ingenuity
each picture must be tailor-made to the
specifications outlined by the art director
of the advertising agency requesting it an
illustrative photographer must be imaginative
for he never knows what sort of advertising
picture he will be asked to make on short notice
jobs requiring reproduction of outdoor
settings or large interior scenes
can only be handled by those who have big
studios but there are many advertising
photographs which can be made on tabletops or
in close quarters making this type of picture
gives the smaller operator a chance in
the field of illustrative photography
the commercial photographer is
often called a jack of all trades
he must be prepared to go anywhere to
take pictures in addition to those he
makes in his studio today he may be shooting the
exterior of a building for a real estate operator
tomorrow he may be in a factory making a series
of pictures showing a manufacturing process
yes the commercial man's pictures are likely to
include anything and everything machinery food
poultry buildings and so on because of this great
variety of work the commercial photographer's
field tends to overlap those of the portrait man
and the illustrative photographer some of his
shots may even be used by the press but basically
press or news photography is a field in itself
contrary to popular opinion a press photographer's
life is not just one big thrill after another
he does shoot exciting scenes from time to
time but such events are the exception most
of his work is routine in nature consisting
mainly of pictures of people and places
connected with the news nevertheless the news
photographer must work expertly at high speed
and know what constitutes a news picture
similar to press photography is newsreel work
but it is difficult to enter as a cameraman
because the field is overcrowded this also is
true of theatrical motion picture production
in addition it takes years of training and
experience to master the complicated cameras the
lighting problems and the use of special effects
and in spite of these rigid requirements
hollywood has more cameramen than opportunities
but there are other jobs in
motion picture production
not only for the theater but also in educational
industrial and other non-theatrical films
there are many small producers
specializing in this type of picture
the whole field of photography offers numerous
positions that do not call for actual camera
work but provide valuable training to
those who want to become photographers
laboratory or darkroom assistants and technicians
have an opportunity to learn how to mix chemicals
to develop films to retouch negatives and to
make prints studio assistants and cameramen's
helpers have a chance to learn the practical
side of professional work they become familiar
with equipment which the average amateur doesn't
use they learn how lights are placed to achieve
the balance between highlight and shadow
which is necessary for all good pictures
working as a salesman in a photo supply
store is another way to gain experience
the best salesman are those who know photography
and are able to answer the customer's many
requests for advice establishing your own camera
shop or photo finishing service is a possibility
for one who learns the business and has
the necessary capital another possibility
is working for one of the big manufacturers
of photographic equipment and supplies these
factories employ thousands of persons from machine
operators to highly trained engineers and chemists
persons who are interested in photography can
start it as a hobby to be followed during spare
time while holding a job or attending school some
schools have photography departments and camera
clubs many students acquire practical experience
by making pictures for the school paper and
yearbook you can learn a great deal by reading the
many excellent books and magazines on the subject
and there are numerous exhibitions where
you can learn by studying the work of
well-known photographers there are private
schools of photography in the large cities
offering complete courses of training to prepare
you for any type of professional still work
you may find that you prefer to
photograph a certain type of subject
many photographers owe their success to
specialization it might be still life babies
animals aerial views airplanes sports
scenics railroads medicine or fashions
there is almost no end to special subjects
and some amateurs have made their hobby pay by
selling prints to photo syndicates or to magazines
and newspapers interested in a particular type
picture editors on the staffs of publications
are always on the lookout for good pictures
and here too is another job for the person who
knows photography the position of picture editor
this work is open to both men and women whose
background and training fit the photographic and
journalistic requirements of certain publications
the photo engraving departments of publications
and printing concerns offer still another type of
work thus the field of photography is broad enough
to provide opportunities to thousands of persons
with various aptitudes interests and educational
backgrounds new applications for photography are
constantly being discovered and new materials and
tools are being produced just what place you
might take in this growing industry depends on
your abilities and inclinations but if you have a
sincere interest in photographic work it would be
worthwhile to investigate the field carefully some
phase of photography may become your life work